hey nobody's perfect Avengers endgame
might be the biggest movie in the world
but that doesn't mean it's immune from
those nagging continuity errors that can
be found in virtually every Hollywood
production including many of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe entries that came
before it in case you're not hip to the
lingo a continuity error such as the
ones that plagued 2008 Iron Man usually
happens when a cut between scenes imply
a series of events that well shouldn't
be possible such as the characters drink
suddenly going from empty to full from
one shot to the next an end game fans
have spotted a pretty egregious example
and it has to do with Scott Lang you may
only want to keep watching if you've
seen the flick because we'll be getting
into some spoilers the glitch occurs
near the end of the film during the
monumental battle between Thanos and his
invading forces and the Avengers
alongside all of the returned heroes and
the entire wakandan army but you don't
need a whole recap right Avengers so
they're fighting this purple guy of the
universe and he won and may die anyway
during the melee laying and hope Van
Dyne are making their way through the
chaos in an attempt to reach Scott Sven
still housing the quantum tunnel it's a
nifty little scene with ant-man and the
wasp suddenly thrust back into action
together once again but the very next
shot is a wide one of the two opposing
forces clashing on the battlefield there
in the middle of it all is laying in his
giant man form whoops
directors Joe and Anthony Russo have
been going gangbusters explaining to the
press some of endgames perceived plot
holes and mistakes but unless you're
gonna tell us that it was actually Hank
Pym or Bill Foster wearing an extra
ant-man suit or something we're pretty
sure this is a big old fat error that
falls directly on the film's editors
film productions generally employ one or
more script supervisors whose job it is
to make sure that seemingly
insignificant details remain consistent
between multiple takes of the same scene
when they drop the ball things can start
getting a little glitchy but often such
as in the case of this scene it comes
down to a simple oversight during the
editing stage if the sequence had been
cut differently it may have appeared
that laying has
left Van Dyne on her own in order to go
big and rejoin the fray but as it stands
he appears to be in two places at the
same time ant-man may be resourceful but
he's no loki as we previously mentioned
it can be nearly impossible to squeeze
every last continuity error out of a
film editors are often left with a less
than desirable choice of shots to piece
together and continuity can be tough to
maintain when various tapes of the same
scene are shot weeks apart for example
the mighty Marvel Cinematic Universe is
no exception
and trained as its rabid fans are to
always be on the lookout for tiny Easter
Egg II details very few of its
continuity errors go unnoticed the goofs
section of the IMDB page for inaugural
entry iron man alone lists a whopping
two dozen mistakes and continuity
including Starks tip disappearing from
the tip jar the color of the camera lens
on Tony's phone changing between cuts
and even the length of Starks goatee
going from pencil-thin to full and fuzzy
over the course of one short night
mistakes such as these are pretty easy
to spot if you're on the lookout for
them and let's face it the only real
surprise here is that this is the only
continuity error that has been spotted
and in games so far with the flick only
having been in theaters for a short time
it probably won't be long before fans
going back for repeat viewings point out
a bunch more does it seem a little bit
ridiculous for such an easily spotted
gaffe to show up in such a highly
anticipated box-office juggernaut of a
film a little bit sure does set gap
diminish our enjoyment of Avengers
endgame even one iota absolutely not
then again it's a little tougher than
usual to zero in on tiny on-screen
errors when you're crying tears of pure
joy check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about the Marvel Cinematic Universe are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]